CLICK SUCH A GREAT SONG THERE.
WELCOME BACK TO BEXAR TO SHOW.
PART THREE OF ELON MUSK WITH
YOUR FILES CONFIRM FEDERAL
AGENCIES LIKE THE FBI AND DHS
WERE CLOSER TWITTER EXECUTIVES
TO CENSOR CONSERVATIVES.
TWEET NUMBER 17 DURING THIS TIME
EXECUTIVES WERE ALSO CLEARLY
ONLY A ZONING WITH FEDERAL
ENFORCEMENT AND INTELLIGENCE
AGENCY ABOUT THE MODERATION OF
ELECTION RELATED CONTENT.
MATT REPORTS EXTENDED
COORDINATION TO THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY.
HER SUITE NUMBER 20 THIS POST
ABOUT THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP
SITUATION SHOWS ROTH NOT ONLY
MET WEEKLY WITH THE FBI AND DHS
BUT WITH THE OFFICE OF THE
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE.
THIS IS COMING OUT SHORTLY AFTER
TWEEDY'S LUNCHEON TWITTER SAFETY
CHIEF QUITS.
HE ADMITTED CENSORING THE LAPTOP
WAS WRONG.
I WANT TO GO TO OUR OG HARRIS
FAULKNER.
SHE YOU ARE THE VENTURE WE LOVE
YOU.
AS YESTERDAY HAD KEVIN MCCARTHY
ON YOUR SHOW.
HE DESCRIBED WHAT HE BELIEVED
WAS NEXT TO THE TWITTER STORY
LET'S LISTEN TO GETS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> PERFECT.
>> WE ARE NOW KNOW THAT DIRECT
CORRELATION DIRECT ABILITY TO
SPEAK TO ONE ANOTHER.
THEY WOULD TELL THEM WHEN THEY
WERE IDENTIFYING THESE
CONSERVATIVES THAT SHOULD NO
LONGER HAVE FREE SPEECH SHOULD
GO AFTER A DOCTOR AT STANFORD.
TO GO AFTER THIS DR. SIMPLY
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO GIVE HIS
OPINION.
THEY WANTED CONTROL OVER US.
WE WATCH THIS GOVERNMENT ONE IN
CONTROL SO MUCH THEY USED
COMPANIES TO DO IT AND THESE
COMPANIES SHIELDED THEMSELVES
UNDER SECTION 2:30.
JANUARY 3 CANNOT COME FAST
ENOUGH.
>> AND HE MEANS IT.
>> HE DOES AND MATT TAIBBI.
>> THERE IS SO MUCH WE DO NOT
KNOW.
IN THE ONE OF THE THINGS LEADER
MCCARTHY WAS SAYING AND HE IS
NOW THE SPEAKER DESIGNATE AS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO JANUARY.
WE'LL SEE HOW THAT WORKS OUT.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE WAS SAYING
WHO ELSE WAS DOING THIS DANCE?
MAYBE IT WASN'T ONLY TWITTER.
TALK ABOUT BLACKLISTING AND ALL
OF THAT WHO ELSE HAD ACCESS TO
THAT INFORMATION?
DID OTHER SOCIAL PLATFORMS SELL,
BARTER, SHARE THAT INFORMATION?
ARE WE BEING QUIETED AS PEOPLE
IN GENERAL AND CONSERVATIVES IN
PARTICULAR OVER AND OVER AGAIN
ON OTHER PLATFORMS DON'T EVEN
KNOW?
THEN DAN BONGINO AND OTHERS
PICKED IT UP PRETTY EARLY BUT
THEY WOULD PUT A TWEET OUT IN
CERTAIN THINGS WE GET A LOT OF
HEAT.
THEY WOULD TREND IN CERTAIN
OTHER THINGS TOUCHED ON COVID OR
TOUCHED ON THINGS LIKE THE
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP COVERAGE
THAT WAS BROKEN BY THE "NEW YORK
POST".
ALL OF THAT REPORTING WAS
CLAMPED DOWN ON PRINTING AND
TWEETED ABOUT WAS STICKERED OR
SLOW DOWN IN THIS PROCESS OF
FILTERING THE VISIBILITY OF
THOSE TWEETS.
WHICH BY THE WAYS WE CALL
CRUSHING FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
YOU THINK YOU ARE FREE OF SPEECH
ON A PLATFORM IN YOUR BEING
WORKED AGAINST WITHOUT YOUR
KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT, THAT IS
NOT RATES AND THAT IS WHERE
KEVIN MCCARTHY AND THE
REPUBLICANS WENT TO GET TOO.
THEY WANT TO GO AFTER IT AND SEE
WHO ELSE WAS DOING THIS.
>> INTO YOUR POINT ESPECIALLY
MENTIONING OUR VERY OWN DAN
BONGINO, HE HAD SOMETHING TO SAN
FOX AND FRIENDS WE CAN TODAY,
LET'S LISTEN.
>> CAN ANYONE EXPLAIN TO ME HOW
THE FBI, THE DNI AND THE DHS
MEETING WITH A PRIVATE COMPANY
AND WINKING AND NODDING
SUGGESTING THEY RESTRICT PEOPLES
OF FREE SPEECH, CAN YOU PLEASE
EXPLAIN TO ME HOW THAT DOES NOT
RELATE THE FIRST AMENDMENT THE
NEXT SHOE TO DROP IS HOW THEY
COLLABORATE WITH EACH OTHER.
>> DAN ALSO NAMED TWITTER
ACCOUNT ON A BLACKLIST TO CENSOR
HIM HE WILL DIVE INTO THE NIGHT
ON UNFILTERED WITH DAN BONGINO
AT 9:00 P.M. EASTERN ON THIS
CHANNEL.
TOMI, I WANT TO GO TO YOU.
ONE OF THE LARGEST SOCIAL MEDIA
FOLLOWINGS ON ANY CONSERVATIVE
MILLIONS ON INSTAGRAM, TWITTER,
ALL AROUND.
YOU HAVE BEEN SHADOW BAND BEFORE
HAVEN'T YOU?
>> ON THE MOVING SHADOW BAND
DISCUSSION FACEBOOK AN INSTAGRAM
IT IS STILL HAPPENING.
THE QUESTION YOU ASKED KAMALA
HARRIS IS HAPPENING OTHER
PLATFORMS?
YES IN ON STEROIDS IS STILL
HAPPENING.
AT LEAST TWITTER GOT REAL OR CO-
ADVICE FOR THE MOST PART.
INSTAGRAM, FACEBOOK THEY STILL
HAVE THEM.
WE TALK ABOUT A MASTER
BLACKLIST, YES, I DO THINK ONE
EXISTS.
THINK ALL THE BIG TECH COMPANIES
INCLUDING THE SEARCH ENGINES, I
THINK THEY ALL OPERATE ON
EVERYTHING I HOPE YOU'RE
REPUBLICANS ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
DIVING INTO THIS.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS I HAVE HAD
THIS FRUSTRATION FOR YEARS NOW.
YES WE HAVE TWITTER FILES WE
HAVE THAT VALIDATION WE WERE
LOOKING FOR THE REPUBLICANS,
CONSERVATIVES WE KNOW THIS IS
BEEN HAPPENING FOR YEARS PETER
REPUBLICANS HAVE TALKED ABOUT
IT, THEY TALKED ABOUT SECTION
2:30.
NOTE SIX ELON MUSK TO DO
SOMETHING FOR THEM SORRY
CONSERVATIVES AND THOSE WITH
PLATFORMS HAVE BEEN BEGGING FOR
THIS FOR YEARS NOW.
HAPPY SOMETHING IS BEING DONE.
THAT SHOULD NOT TAKE ELON MUSK
TO DO IT REALLY SHOULDN'T.
>> IT REALLY SHOULDN'T.
JACK DORSEY THE FOUNDER OF
TWITTER HAS BEEN UNDER OATH
BEFORE CONGRESS MULTIPLE TIMES.
DID HE LIE IS THE QUESTION?
THAT LET'S WATCH.
>> SOCIAL MEDIA IS BEING RIGGED
TO CENSOR CONSERVATIVES IS THAT
TRUE OF TWITTER?
>> NO.
>> I DO NOT KNOW TWITTER IS UP
TO IT SURE LOOKS TO ME LIKE THEY
ARE CENSURING PEOPLE THEY OUGHT
TO STOP IT, ARE YOU CENSORING
PEOPLE?
>> NO.
TWITTER SHADOW BATTING PROMINENT
REPUBLICANS IS BAD, IS THAT
TRUE?
>> NO.
>> YOU ARE THE CHAIRMAN OF
OVERSIGHT AND YOU HAVE SEEN THIS
KIND OF STUFF AND PRODUCING
PEOPLE LIE BEFORE YOU.
WILL THE BE CONSEQUENCES FOR
JACK DORSEY?
THAT CLEARLY LOOKS LIKE A LIE TO
ME.
YOU AGREE WITH THE REGULAR INK
TWITTER AND SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES?
>> THINK WHAT HE SAYING THERE IS
FALSE IS DEMONSTRATIVELY FALSE.
IT CAN BE PROVEN YOUNG SOUK IN
FILES THAT WERE REVEALED THE
DEMOCRAT WHO ACTUALLY STEPPED UP
AND SAID I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
DEFEND WHAT YOU ARE DOING HERE,
TWITTER.
UNDERSTEER OF THE CIA AND THE
NSA, HOMELAND SECURITY AND A
HOST OF OTHER AGENCIES THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION
WOULD SAY WE ARE SEEING RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE WE ARE SEEING
CHINESE ACTIVITY YOU WEAR.
THEY DO THAT IN MULTIPLE
DISTRICTS.
WHAT IS OVERSTEPPING HERE WHICH
IS TOTALLY FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG
IT WAS THEN MORPHED INTO A
POLITICAL OPERATION TO TARGET
JUST ONE PARTY.
NOT THE ONES AROUND BOTH SIDES
AVAILABLE JUST CONSERVATIVES AND
JUST REPUBLICANS.
IT WAS USE A POLITICAL
BLUDGEONING TOOL.
THAT'S WHAT OVERSTEPS THE LINE.
THAT'S WHERE THERE'S GOING TO A
WHOLE SLEW OF LAWSUITS ABOUT
ELECTION ENGINEERING AND
ELECTION MANIPULATION.
THAT IS WHAT SHOULD SCARE ALL OF
US.
BY THE WAY THESE TWITTER
COMPANIES AND SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES HAVE SECTION 2:30
WHICH GIVES THEM THE LIABILITY
PROTECTION.
THAT WILL CHANGE IN CONGRESS.
>> HE MAY OR MAY NOT PAY THE
PRICE FOR THIS.
>> I'M SO FRUSTRATED I'VE NEVER
SEEN